there have been a series of attacks in
chicago by roving gangs of teenagers and
we've got a local news report on one of
the latest attacks a woman was beaten by
a group of teens mostly boys it would
seem
and she's in critical condition now
she's got a fractured skull lacerations
lots of damage
here's the report on that
a rideshare driver gave us this video
look closely at the intersection as the
driver pulls up to the red light here at
jackson and state around 11 30 saturday
night
you can see the woman is being dragged
you can also hear her screaming
a man in a white shirt tries to help her
he starts to fight with the teens that
are attacking her as the woman gets up
and starts to walk away
watch as one of the teens grabs what
appears to be a bag that was left on the
street he calmly walks away with it the
woman gets up and tries to walk
she stumbles then collapses to the
ground the man in the white shirt again
comes to help her as some of the teens
ride away on divi bikes as the ride
share driver goes through the
intersection look to your right
some of the teens with bikes are making
their way down the stairs to a cta
platform this incident is one of five
attacks on people in the loop between
saturday and monday police say in each
case groups of three to 12 teens go up
to victims and demand to have their
belongings the victims are then
surrounded and beaten by the teens using
their hands and feet until the victim
gives up their property
uh
nothing new there in chicago
eventually maybe
we all see these stories all the time in
places like chicago and baltimore and
every other major city in the country
um this kind of violence that
yeah ostensibly they're doing it to rob
the woman which is bad enough on its own
but it's pretty clear that it's it's not
really even about
taking her belongings
i mean that would be that would be
horrible that would be better than what
is the reality and the reality is that
they're just doing it for fun
and uh
the the taking the purse is sort of a
prize at the end of it
icing on the cake for them really
really it's simply the thrill of
victimizing an innocent person and
beating them for the sake of it
eventually maybe we'll get around asking
the question
of uh
how are we raising kids
what's going on
in a child's life and these are not
these are not children these are you
know i would call them young adults
but what's going on in a child's life
that they would turn into that
i mean when you look at cities across
the country and you see these
violent thugs
with with just no
conscience at all
you know committing these acts of
brutality and barbarism for the fun of
it what how does that happen how do you
end up with that
but these are the conversations we can't
have so usually we're just gonna we're
gonna talk about if there was a gun
involved there's a reason we're not
hearing about this at all in the in the
mainstream media i mean the local media
is talking about mainstream media
national media is not talking about it
because there's no gun involved here
they just use their fists and whatever
other object whatever other blunt
instruments they have around to beat
unsuspecting women with
if there's a gun then they'll talk about
the gun and how did it end up that these
uh these kids have got their hands on on
a gun
but even then we're not gonna talk about
well it's okay they got their hands on a
gun what what prompted them to use it in
that way
you had a case uh last week i remember
what city it was in i want to say it was
maybe new york
and this was caught on camera there was
a fight outside of a shoe store about
shoes
and one of the employees from the shoe
store came out to try to disperse things
courageously really and he got she was
shot and killed
you did hear a little bit about that
because of the gun and so we're told
well he had a gun
how did this young man get this gun
gun violence is a big problem
that's not really my question
my question is okay he had the gun
why would he want to use it like that
what's going on in his mind
that would make him want to kill another
person over a fight over shoes
that's the real question that's that's
that's the discussion we simply can't
have apparently
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated